[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances foster and constant Kissin and
this is the show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
Matt Goodwin who is a professor of
political science at the University of
Kent and a senior fellow at Chatham
House Matt welcome to trigonometry
[Music]
thanks for having me it's great to have
you and listen the question we always
ask is who are you what's your
background how are you where you are
what's your interest in some of the
things that we're gonna be talking about
yeah well I'm an academic I've been in
political science the study of politics
for 15 years something like that
I I got interested in populism I think
really during the early 2000s late 1990s
early 2000s I was doing my undergraduate
dissertation on what was going on in
Austria at the time and Austria was one
of the first democracies in Europe to
have a national populist party really
joining a national government in a way
that got global attention had been some
stuff in Italy prior but and I found
myself in Austria running around sort of
talking to all of these national
populace asking them what they were
trying to do and so on and from there or
and it kind of became this real interest
in in trying to understand you know
really why people were voting for those
movements where they were coming from
and how they were trying to change their
countries and and then over the years I
I started doing some pretty interesting
research projects my PhD I was I was
interviewing the harder end of that
scene talking to a lot of folks on the
extreme right wing about why they became
active why they join these these parties
and movements that were even further to
the right the National populace and then
yeah when the academic route got a got a
job at Manchester and then and then
Nottingham and then ended up where I've
now at Kent and I'm doing some work with
think tanks along the way and you're
about to release book literally in a
couple of days about national populism
we'll get into that and it's fascinating
thank you for sending us a copy we've
had a chance to look through some of it
first of all define national populism
for us because I think some people don't
really understand what we're talking
about people see brexit and Trump and
these movements in Europe happening but
they don't have quite a solid idea of
what it is that we're talking about so
who are these people what's their agenda
yeah so there's a bit of a debate about
how to define all of these movements but
basically I refer to national
populace as being really movements that
want to prioritize the the nation and
the common plane people against
political media social elites that have
often held the people in contempt or
certainly have neglected them on a
number of key issues and national
populism is quite different from left
wing populism left wing populist
prioritize class allegiance national
populist prioritize the nation and a
particular conception of of the nation
and not all of the things that tend to
get lumped into that category are
necessarily national populist brexit had
elements of national populism but it
wasn't exclusively a national popular
serve all in the same way that Donald
Trump had elements of national populism
but he was also too a Republican
candidate at a presidential election but
in Europe it's a bit more different we
have movements that are firmly outside
of the mainstream that are I would argue
equivocally unequivocally national
national populist and and they all build
on a very long tradition
in democracy that that goes back as as
long as we've had democracy that as long
as we've been participating in elections
voting for parties we've had national
populace so it's been with us for a very
long time obviously we've seen a rise
how much of that has got to do with the
economic crash in 2008 hmm well this is
a million-dollar question right so if
you're on the Left you basically argue
and I'm not some peeking judgments I
don't know why your politics are got an
idea but if you if you lean left words
you tend to say all of this is about
economic scarcity right it's the old
Marxist line that effectively anybody
who votes for nationalist movements or
movements that express unease about mass
immigration that they are driven by
their worries over basically income
wages and and scarce economic goods and
that usually an extension of their
argument is that the people are being
manipulated by ruthless elites in
society whether it's the media whether
it's these conspiratorial you know
right-wingers trying to divide and rule
the evidence I would argue and certainly
we argue in the book is pretty
overwhelming in pointing in a different
direction which is that if you think for
example about some of the most
successful national populace that we've
had in the Western world coming in
places like Switzerland in Austria the
Netherlands they broke through amid very
low unemployment rates some of the
lowest unemployment rates in Europe very
strong growing economies look at law and
justice in Poland really came into power
on the back of a rapid economic
expansion take Britain Nigel Farage in
the UK Independence Party first really
broke through in 2004 after 48
consecutive periods of growth and then
when we drill down to the individual
level and we look at who's actually
supporting these movements and Michele
will come back to it they tend to be
working full time they tend to often be
on not amazing wages but you know
standard average wages and so the
unemployed the kind of real losers of
globalization in a sort of visceral
sense they are not generally providing
the bulk of support to national populism
and it's worth remembering even in
nineteen in the 1930s many people on the
left like that comparison at the moment
a lot of the unemployed and those who
are out of work actually voting for the
Communists
not for the National Socialists and
National Socialism national populism are
two very different movements but the
idea that the Left push is that this is
all about economic scarcity I'm afraid
is not actually very convincing when you
look at the evidence one of the
interesting points in the book is the
one of the in fact you cite in the book
is that Donald Trump voters I've had the
average highest income of the three
available candidates so if you take
Bernie Sanders Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump
his voice has actually had a higher
average income than any of the other two
and I wanted to come back to the fact
that you've been talking about this for
a long time actually you've been
predicting this unlike most people who
predicted brexit and Trump very
confidently after it happened right you
actually predicted that many years
before you've been talking about this
since like 2010 at least from what I've
seen
with economist for example where you
were talking actually about Anders
Breivik I think in the context of this
and that is not a time in which we were
having these conversations at all so can
you take us back through that period if
it's not the economic crash that Francis
asked you about what has happened over
the last 10 to 15 years that has caused
this movement to emerge in this way yeah
well one of my pet frustrations about
the public debate is that we focus on
the short term factors right and we
obsessed about what happens during
campaigns I mean I just finished reading
Hillary Clinton's book what happened and
I realized she still doesn't know what
happens because she's obsessed with what
what happened during that campaign
period now I would say actually if you
don't if you look not that the last 10
to 15 years but actually at the last 30
to 40 years you can really see a number
of deep currents begin to come forward
and start to reshape democracies in the
West quietly but in a powerful way from
below creating the conditions that have
allowed national populism today to get
to the levels of support that with that
we're seeing and this is partly about a
backlash to the rise of what you might
call the new left in the 60s and the 70s
which pushed a very liberal agenda the
expansion of rights for minorities the
support if not celebration of mass
immigration the shift towards
supranational institutions like the
European Union and in the 80s and the
90s in particularly in countries like
France and Austria you began to see the
beginnings of a backlash to that new
liberal consensus jean-marie lepen for
example he used to run on the slogan
lepen of the people yeah or the Austrian
Freedom Party in York hyder
an earlier generation of populist that
we now tend to forget because we like to
think everything is unique to our era
jörg Haider used to say I say what the
people think right and it was that
notion that he's tapping into a concern
particularly among a lot an alliance of
social conservatives that were often
quite affluent and blue-collar workers
who together felt very uncomfortable
with both the scale and the pace of
change that was happening within the
broader nation and that was partly about
immigration it was also about in some
countries increasingly a political
establishment that seemed to be holding
the people in contempt certainly
neglecting them and also increasingly in
more recent years the specific issue of
Islam in Europe and the refugee crisis
that followed so by the time you get to
really the 90s or 2000s and you guys
start going through things like 9/11
long before the financial crisis you're
beginning to see these movements
actually reaching very high levels of
support in some countries joining
national governments often doing well in
very prosperous affluent areas and
really winning over low-skilled service
workers the self-employed blue-collar
workers so we talk a lot about the
collapse of social democracy today
actually you can really be trace that to
the early to mid 2000s and now the
crisis kicked in and no one's saying the
crisis isn't important because it is and
it wasn't the underlying driver but it
did exacerbate a number of these
emerging value conflicts in the West
between kind of culturally liberal
middle class professionals and those
social conservatives and workers and you
begin to see this kind of gradual
polarization within a lot of Western
democracies and I think what mattered in
a big way was the national populace
themselves also changed they became more
articulate they became more
sophisticated they started to tone down
white supremacism they started to
basically get a bit more in line with
where public opinion really was on these
issues
people like builders started to say well
let's be pro-lgbt
but also let's be anti Islam at the same
time so you started to see these kind of
curious innovations that we didn't
really have before and of course that
then really brought together you know
the public demand for a sort of a
challenge to that liberal consensus with
the sort of party supply with these
parties just being a bit more competent
a bit more articulate at how they're
bringing these groups into the political
system and today where we are
you know I think the interesting macro
question at least is when you look at
what's happening in the West there's
this signal that we are at the end of a
period of great change and volatility
well does it instead signal that we are
at the beginning of a new period of
great change fragmentation and
polarization my view is if you look at
all the evidence we are very much at the
beginning of a new period of great
change and volatility and these
movements will write that wave so you
know with populism right now I've got a
lot of friends you may have a PhD you
may be a professor
I've got mates you've read a couple of
Guardian articles and they've told me
that populism is racism is this right so
no that's not not right surprise so
there are racist voters who are drawn
international populism right there's no
no nobody is denying that I but I think
that the bait particularly on the Left
dare I say The Guardian I have many of
the same friends by the way with that
within academia especially you know
there is a default there's a there's a
view that you know populism equals
fascism populism equals racism and some
of my colleagues I think of given up on
the search for truth and have become
social justice activists who are more
interested in pushing a political agenda
than they are in actually interrogating
the evidence if you look at the evidence
there is a minority of national populist
voters who certainly subscribe to avert
the racist xenophobic views that argue
you can only really be British if you
were born in the country and if you're
you know father and mother and
grandparents were born in the country
and they hold that very narrow ethnic
conception but there are a lot more
voters than those within the national
populist electorate the distance
themselves from those very narrow kind
of race-based conceptions that say
actually I'm not you know when I think
about who's in the nation I would like
people to speak the language I'd like
them to share some of the customs and
traditions I'd like them to integrate
into the national community
and I feel for example completely
comfortable with minority rights with
LGBT communities but I have some
specific concerns over the extent to
which the pace of this change is
actually being able to be managed and is
and these new communities are being
integrated into into the national into
the national community and that isn't
about race at all and these movements as
well I think have not not just out of
strategy I do think part of it is a
sincere generational change within the
national populist movements themselves
you know they are very different from
what we saw in the 60s 70s in the 80s
the the likes of Golden Dawn in Greece
which is a basically a neo-nazi party is
very much an outlier now I did a lot of
work for example on the UK Independence
Party looking at kind of that movement
and how it was organizing and lots of UK
Independence Party leaders and activists
were completely comfortable with non
non-white Britons black minority ethnic
Britons many of them were in the party
they were active but they did have
specific concerns over that issue of of
the pace and the scale of demographic
change and wanting to slow that down and
I think the problem for the left is it's
drawn a straight line between populism
and fascism or populism and racism and
it's fueled as a consequence of that the
sense among voters and actually then the
left really isn't interested in having a
conversation about these legitimate
grievances over community communities
being changed sense of community decline
community loss concerns over who's in
the social contract who's not actually
interested in joining that social
contract and as a consequence I don't
think it's a it's it's a coincidence
that national populism has arisen
at the same time as social democracy has
collapsed because I think the way in
which the left has responded to this is
really exacerbated its decline you tell
me that calling someone a racist doesn't
help the situation
well we have a lot of evidence
suggesting that it makes things worse
right and we've got we've got a lot of
evidence now coming out on the kind of
political correctness agenda social
norms that if you're if you're
brandishing somebody you know it in that
way then actually what you're doing is
you're encouraging that backlash and
you're basically creating the conditions
under which people are more likely to
abandon the mainstream and go over to to
national populism and these parties are
you know doing a reasonable job of
exploiting that that unfortunate
strategy on on the left and you know we
have to try and get get past this moment
in the West where we associate any
airing of grievances over migration as
racism because if we don't get over it
we're going to end up with incredibly
polarized societies and the kind of
polarization that we can begin to see
now in the US for example in the u.s.
when ninety percent of people say
support interracial marriage but but but
now we're seeing over fifty percent of
some in some groups saying I'd be
uncomfortable if my son or daughter
married somebody from the other
political tribe you begin you're
beginning to see the building blocks of
a polarization that actually I find
incredibly worrying and in Europe you
can begin to see the same and and and
this is partly why I'm increasingly
perhaps provocative and controversial
within within academia is that there are
still many who who refuse to accept the
what we're seeing through the prism of
national populism and is an expression
of of grievances that are partly
legitimate and we need to respond to
those it's perfectly legitimate to talk
about prioritizing citizens over
non-citizens is perfectly legitimate to
talk about integration what isn't
working and it's perfectly legitimate to
say we'd quite like to reform the
migration system in order to be more
responsive to what ordinary people want
those are perfectly legitimate
grievances unfortunately the the left in
general is terrible at actually having
that conversation and why do you think
that is I think it's a combination of
factors I think partly is about
it's a genuine I think the left was
essentially hijacked in the 60s and 70s
by a philosophical movement that really
had no real interest in engaging with
anything that wasn't part of its broader
agenda that it was a movement that I
think was very much around the
prioritization of minority rights and
identity politics that we all familiar
with and I don't need to rehash what
that is and how it came here but but
very much prioritized that at the
expense of sustaining and replenishing
its relationship with traditional voters
on the left and I think that that was a
big strategic mistake and we're still
living through the consequences of that
but it's also exacerbated by social
networks and so many people on the Left
kind of constantly within their own
bubbles within their own orbits that
they don't have many networks they don't
have many links outside of those and
that fuels this disconnection I mean I'm
from a you know I grew up in a
working-class community you know
single-parent household most of my mates
are in construction or you know non
non-academic non-elite if you like
industries and I think increasingly
we're seeing this sort of coming apart
or tearing a part of of that that Center
ground and it's going to have I think
incredibly negative effects and so my
line on this in terms of where we're
going over the future is that as we
polarize and as we've seen through the
brexit debate there are lots of people
on the left that simply you know who've
been used to feeling like winners and
now feel like losers but consequently
have no interest in actually even having
a conversation with the other side and
that's going to make this law was well
that's what we tried to do on the show
is have these conversations and people
piss people off yeah well that's
definitely part of it but that's what
that's why we've got you here yeah
but generally we tried to have these
honors
conversations because that's the only
way this is ever gonna change I mean
that that was that's my biggest
frustration with what's happening around
these issues is that we're no longer
communicating and then we are going to
be more polarized
[Music]
but I want to take you back to the
chapter in the book which i think is
kind of a key piece of it which is the
bit where you talk about myths and one
of the myths that you you talk about is
the idea that the support from national
populism comes from angry white men
basically Frances tension yeah so you
talk about that and there's a whole
bunch of other myths that you talk about
as and I think just reading it was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because it's
just what we're seeing out there in the
world right now so tell us about that
what are the myths about the typical
populism supporter yeah so the these are
what I call comfort blankets right a lot
of folks who have been outflanked by
this political change have thrown
comfort blankets over themselves to try
and explain it away and one of those is
that this is all about angry old white
guys who are basically gonna die in five
years and they're gonna be replaced by
you know my students you know young
liberal tolerant Corbyn Easter's who are
going to take us into this you know the
sunny uplands of cosmopolitanism
internationalism and never-ending
diversity my god that's horrible
this is what I call The Economist
argument in the Economist loves here
they wheel it out on a weekly basis and
my friends on the liberal left really
love it because the implication of that
argument is you don't actually need to
engage with the grievances you don't
need to actually take this stuff too
seriously because it it's a waiting game
just hold on but the seat belts on let's
just hang on okay right now they're all
dead
okay now he and you saw it in the
aftermath of the 2016 referendum an
economist friend of mine even calculated
that if remainders could hold on till
2022 then that is the moment at which
remain errs will have a clear majority
because enough levers will have died and
therefore basically need to engage the
grievances another you know the
colonists and national newspapers have
also pushed this argument it's the
laziest argument that's going around and
it's all so bloody insulting to be
honest but it's also a factual because
as people get old
they changed their well so here's his
way you can basically easily destroy
that argument one is if you just look at
who's voting for national populace
across Europe it's often the under
forties marine lepen closed the gender
gap last year for the first time in her
party's movement she was as successful
among young women as young men they go
women are racist to Austria the under
forties were very supportive of the
freedom party forty one percent of white
Millennials back Donald Trump half of
thirty five to forty five year olds in
the UK endorsed leaving the Sweden
Democrats strongest among the thirty to
fifty four year olds the alternative for
Germany strongest among the thirty to
fifty year olds I mean the argument
basically is being stretched to its
absolute extreme by lots of what I'll
call hyper liberals because you know
it's a sexy argument right they like it
it kind of conforms to their value said
but generational change takes a long
long long time and secondly the jury and
lifecycle effects is out right so I've
got a colleague at Oxford James Tilly
who's shown that as all of us age will
become nought point three eight percent
more conservative as one year replaces
the next right naught point three eight
percent which doesn't sound like a lot
but if you consider that over the course
of a lifetime that that basically
explains the generational differences in
labour and conservative support among
the different age groups and you know we
do we do it and the second thing to keep
in mind
by the way related to that is I don't
really see much evidence in the survey
data on the new sort of ijen generation
the Millennial Generation these actually
are passionate tolerant liberals who are
going to defend freedom of speech and
have these really big debates and
impractical
you know really hold up the marketplace
of ideas and ensure that the the beating
heart of liberalism continues if
anything I actually I I'm a bit anxious
in that I see evidence to the contrary
that if you look at the debates over
campus campus environments in the u.s.
if you look at some of the evidence in
Europe yes they tend to be socially
liberal but not always as open to
the exchange abused the exchange of
opinions and debate as perhaps we would
we would like them to be so you put that
very mildly mad I mean if you look at
the column at it yeah but I mean you
look at the concept of free speech in
things like academia and things like the
comedy industry which we know very well
it's essentially become a right-wing
issue well there are lots of people who
when you point this out will say oh the
problem when universities is being
stoked up by people who are causing
problems right and then you see actual
real world events going on around we're
using well actually I'm not sure this is
being blown up any of you look for
example at the recent started my
university which has just decided that
or at least the Union has has decided
that people dressing up as Cowboys is a
sort of you know cultural appropriation
and complete seem to be offensive and
unfortunately for me actually the guy
who pushed that argument was also called
Matt Goodwin so I suddenly found I woke
up one morning my email was stack full
of you know email saying what on earth
are you doing I actually quite the
contrary I think people should dress up
in whatever you know whatever they want
to dress up in them be offensive yeah
yeah indeed but the but the argument is
very real and and and the evidence is
certainly there and it's good to see the
u.s. now having a much more vigorous
debate about that and where we're headed
but the angry old my old white man
narrative also ignores the fact that we
have generations particularly Europe jet
new generations that are going to feel
left behind in their own way that if
you're grappling with youth unemployment
rates of ten to fifteen percent in
southern Europe if you are struggling to
you know get a hundred grand to deposit
for our house in London if you are
keenly aware as my students are that
they've got a pretty crap deal compared
to their baby boomer parents or
grandparents then I would argue the
conditions the underlying conditions
that partly fuel national populism that
sense of relative loss or relative
deprivation and also some concerns over
the speed at which societies are being
transformed I think these movements are
going to continue to have a lot of gas
in the tank in Austria for example they
campaign for votes in nightclubs I mean
something
equivalent of nigel farage going to the
ministry of sound or something they'll
just be very bizarre but the the youth
and in Hungary in Central and Eastern
Europe - by the way the youth folks very
important to these parties now you were
pointing out about the different types
of people who vote we didn't really
touch a pony at quite a lot of ethnic
minorities for instance my mother is a
Latin American woman and she loves Trump
and she votes it breaks it
well when Vince Cable came out and said
you know the the vote for breaks it was
a kind of a backlash among old white
people that want to return to the days
of empire it was a very ill judged
intervention it's also completely
disconnected from the evidence right one
in three black or minority ethnic voters
in Britain endorsed leaving the European
Union and my frustration I suppose with
the media's we've had a lot of Vox pops
with the white working-class from Stoke
and Burnley and Clacton I'm all great
house but we haven't seen many similar
Vox pops in Birmingham Slough Luton with
minority communities that also voted
leave in the same way we haven't heard
much about the one in three Hispanic
Latino voters in the u.s. that endorsed
Trump cuban-americans in Florida me
Jewish activists in Europe that have got
involved with national populism because
they I think have made a strategic
trade-off in a way in in viewing these
movements as being more serious about
countering sort of the perceived threat
from from Islam than the mainstream
parties and so I think that we're going
to hopefully get into a debate that
acknowledges that these electorates that
are supporting these movements are more
diverse than many commentators and
thinkers would have us believe and when
you look at why minorities voted to
leave the European Union a strong sense
that goes back to the point about young
people that they were being left behind
or excluded at the expense of others the
EU Nationals were being given preference
to the UK at the expense of their
relatives friends and networks from
South Asia for example also a straw
sense of social conservativism that they
like other social conservatives value
stability of group conformity with in a
sort of quite diverse conception of the
nation and aren't really down with this
never-ending social change argument that
the liberals really love I mean the
analogy I use you know as a sort of the
Tony Blair argument was you know your
honor
you're on a train and it's going 300
miles an hour the train is called
globalization you can't get off and it's
inevitable you just have to stay on and
that was effectively Blair's argument in
his 2005 conference speech
what are these voters I think now saying
actually well we can get off the train
we can try and slow down the pace of
change and there's this concept that I
think national populism offers which is
this idea that there is an alternative
state right you don't have to just be
down with this never-ending
constant churn you can try and shift
things in a different direction and the
world might not collapse now that comes
with a lot of negatives to those
movements can be xenophobic they can
ferment grievances and polarization but
even minority voters I think are partly
receptive to that argument of saying
well if you're in the US for example you
might feel that well now you are
established within that national
community you might not necessarily
therefore be down with endless change
and less flux just because you happen to
be from from the same background as new
migrants and new arrivals so that may
increase the jury's out love to see one
of the things I find interesting about
the political situation at the moment is
that we might sounds like we come from
ceará mere backgrounds in terms of I
come from a working-class area and when
I grew up there was enf and everybody
knew they were right-wing they were
racists they were pretty unabashed
whether they grow in a place called
Morden in South London and and it was
very obvious what they were there was
the NF pub and all the rest of it now
you look a lot of these groups and you
go I don't know whether you're
right-wing or not like the football lads
Alliance who went on a March and then
there was a case where where the team
that I support West Ham had
a coach go along and openly support them
and there's a discussion now whether he
should lose his job or not or the
football lads Alliance a right-wing
group is Tommy Robinson right wing way
doesn't it right way is he far right
absolutely is he far right and all these
different things I mean where do you
stand on this with these types of groups
are they far right are they racist or
there's something more going on there
yeah well with those particular groups
and also groups like pegida in Germany
it's quite it's good they're quite
amorphous they don't really have fixed
borders and they operate outside of
electoral politics which makes it quite
difficult to understand really what
they're about but they are certainly
right-wing in that they are prioritizing
the nation they're certainly not
interested in class allegiance but they
are prioritizing issues of migration and
identity and culture which puts them
firmly on the right are they extreme
right-wing or on a radical right and
traditionally the distinction between
the two is if you're advocating the
overthrow of democracy if you're
anti-democratic if you if you were like
historic fascism and you are
revolutionary you just believe democracy
should be overthrown then you are on the
extreme right wing if alternatively
you're saying I accept democracy I think
democracy as a system of government is
probably what we should have
but I'd quite like to give more power
and influence to ordinary people who
have been shut out of key decisions for
example they haven't been talked to
about these issues of Islamic terrorism
or grooming or female genital mutilation
these issues on which Tommy Robinson and
others campaign then I would say they
are radical right not extreme right-wing
when they trip into violence and when
they trip into openly undermining the
democratic state then they trip into
that extreme right-wing category the
term far-right I just think it's
meaningless because it doesn't really
tell us anything it's if you're on the
far-right well is that Greece Greece is
Golden Dawn is it the UK Independence
Party and if you lump them all under
far-right doesn't really give us that
night
lighting line that we need I've done a
lot of work with police and security
services over the years and and and and
and that's you know and I think that's
where we need to be very careful in how
we categorize these movements National
Action for example which was an
extra-parliamentary extreme right-wing
group that was advocating terrorism and
was banned by the UK state you know was
banned on that basis that it sought to
overthrow the democratic system and
commit violence if not murder but there
are groups within the radical right
orbit football ads Alliance I would say
that are not overtly advocating
terrorist activities are not saying
let's go let's get rid of democracy but
they do feel they tap into that national
populist point which is that they've
been neglected on in terms of their
views about key issues whether that's
relating to the role of Islam its
capacity to integrate whether it's about
the grooming scandal because you know
this is an awkward point right but many
of the people on the radical right who
were talking about child sexual
exploitation in the early 2000s have
partly been legitimized by the
subsequent events that have occurred the
the times have brought attention to this
great journalists like Andrew Norfolk
and others who've really kind of pushed
been been forerunners on that but groups
on the radical right the BNP the English
Defence League we're talking about those
issues in the early 2000s and I wonder
kind of out loud how British politics
might have been different had we
collectively as a society being more
responsive to those issues early on I
mean working-class anger disillusionment
you know was evident in the late 90s
early 2000s if you've been looking at
turnout in some communities like in
South London or the the Midlands
northeast northwest you would have seen
particularly after the Blair's second
landslide in 2001 turnout levels among
working-class voters just start to
decline steadily and by the time you get
to 2010 many of those voters are
basically not voting some of them came
back into the system for the UK
Independence Party some of them then
went back into apathy in 2015 but at the
2016 election a lot of them came out
to vote leave because they felt that
outsider first-past-the-post that was an
opportunity to get those values to get
those views to get that seat at the
table and it came out and voted turnout
let's not forget was higher in working
class districts but it was lower than
average in some of the hipster London
districts of Camden and Shoreditch and
Hackney and I think partly and what data
can't tell us what my suspicion is was
that that's partly about this sense that
listen I I want to be listened to
I've got concerns I want to put them on
the agenda and football out Alliance and
those groups which are on that
borderline I think the risk is if you
don't open up this conversation and you
have it nationally those are the groups
that are closer to that border that will
end up having that conversation and they
will just control that space and they
are significant right those movements
are significant and as the Germans are
discovering when you don't get control
of that conversation you quickly lay the
conditions for a very significant
backlash which partly found its
expression through pegida but also
through the alternative for Germany
[Music]
and it sounds like what you're saying
really is if I'm reading between the
lines is these movements have been
necessary because the elites haven't
been listening the media the the MPs the
Parliament the government hasn't been
listening to the concerns of warning
people things like you talked about the
grooming games you know there's
significant evidence now that the reason
they were able to thrive in these areas
is because of political political
correctness it's because the police the
councils the social services didn't want
to raise the issue that there was an
ethnic component to this problem and so
do you think that the rise of national
populism has been a necessary wake-up
call for for the rest of society so I
think this is really where the debate is
and then the key part of the debate is
very much around do you view populism as
an inherently evil force which many on
the left do and therefore they're not
interested in engaging and thinking
about it seriously or do you instead
view it partly as a corrective as a
movement that absent flows throughout
the history of democracy but it really
comes to the forefront when certain
groups feel that they're not being
listened to and certain issues are not
being addressed that concern a large
number of people
so populism for some writers and
thinkers is a really a sort of a this is
a snap back in the system is the system
has gone too far away from groups or
issues and it's forced to come back into
into those areas in order to deal with
it so that's why there's a it's a
controversial point but the way that's
why some people argue that national
populism has a silver lining in that it
brings these issues back it also brings
groups back into the political system I
mean if you look at the alternative
alternative for Germany
you know the German party system is
rapidly imploding right in front of our
eyes we're seeing mad shifts in in
Germany essentially I mean the SPD is
than one's dominance center-left SPD is
collapsing the AFD is now in 15 of 16
state Parliament's will probably be in
all of them by the end of October 2018
and
also having quite a clear implant impact
on the policy agenda the number one
source of votes for the AFD non-voters
people who didn't vote at the previous
election the brexit referendum I was
involved with an exit poll on the day of
the referendum about 2 million voters
turned out who hadn't voted at the
previous election about 30% of them then
didn't vote at the 2017 election so they
are bringing these non voters back in
that to me is something that is should
be welcomed right that we want the
marketplace of ideas to be as strong as
possible now you might not look you
might not like what national populism is
saying about these issues you might not
like how it frames these issues and
sometimes it does frame them in a in a
xenophobic way but the underlying
grievances are a legitimate ones and
that's certainly the argument in the
book that if you just think about where
the West is heading over the next few
decades a lot of the trends that are
already in place we can't do anything to
stop it now
a lot of the trends that are in place
that are fueling these movements they
are going to accelerate at speeds that
are going to cause a significant sense
of alarm among a large number of voters
I would rather have those voters in the
Democratic marketplace of ideas than
outside of that and pursuing things like
the football at Alliance order the
defense leagues or pegida and that means
I think from my friends on the liberal
left when they're at the table right and
they've they've asked you a question you
have to give a reply you can't ignore it
anymore
you can't duck it for the simple reason
being that your own vote chairs are
rapidly dwindling do you think that
there's any way that this can be
addressed credibly without reducing
immigration so I think immigration is
front and center to the to the
phenomenon and I think that inevitably
particularly Western Europe in the US
will have to
reform immigration in a much more
substantive way that we will have to
slow down migration and we will have to
work in at the same time a lot harder at
how we integrate minorities into the
broader national community and you can
see the beginnings of this already so if
you look at Scandinavia the it's
actually many parties on the Left that
are now endorsing more assertive
policies to try and bring people
together in a meaningful way Denmark for
example has just pledged to end all
parallel societies by 2030 and it's
doing some pretty radical stuff that
will make a lot of people feel
uncomfortable like reducing welfare for
people that choose to live in segregated
neighborhoods knocking down apartment
blocks that have become too segregated
giving people who commit crimes in those
neighborhoods harsher crimes than they
would if they lived in other areas
effectively forcing kids under five to
go into mixed schooling so they have
developed those bridges those links with
other groups with with kids from other
backgrounds and that stuff will make a
lot of people feel uncomfortable but I
think that's the beginning of the
broader direction of travel Europe in
general will have to strengthen external
security and borders considerably just
simply because of the political
pressures that are going to bear down on
liberal Europe especially from Central
and Eastern Europe and it may be over
time that actually internal borders will
have to be a lot stronger than they are
at the moment I mean over the last few
years we've really seen Schengen
not-not-not
not die but certainly be weakened
significantly we've had temporary border
checks and so on and I think simply
because of the mood in the continent
sort of mood music that we know that
these issues are now at the front and
center of people's minds we know that
they're going to I would argue they're
going to stay at the front and center of
people's minds because what they're
going to see over the coming years is
going to be quite troubling
particularly not for the winners if you
like not for the highly educated middle
class professionals or you know nothing
basically at ease with with a lot of
these changes but but but other sections
of society are going to want to push
back very strongly and when you look at
people like macron
you know they're the outlier they're not
the norm the norm now are Conservative
Party's right-wing parties and the
evidence backs backs me up on this
Europe is moving very quickly to the
right in policy terms so a lot of my
liberal left academic colleagues very
excited about the Greens in Bavaria at
the moment I would say show me one study
that shows the Greens having anything
like the policy influence that
conservatives of national populist are
having when you've got left-wing parties
advocating more restrictive migration
measures even Corbin has come out and
said well let's respect the referendum
result then let's reform freedom of
movement you know and I think that
that's that's the beginning of a much
broader shift loves brexit you've been
exactly but but the point is labor on
that on that policy issue are much more
I think to the right if you like than
Blair whatever a being or Chuck Romeo
will ever be in and that's the broader
travel other Democrats in the US are an
exception but I think the Democrats are
going to have a very difficult few years
I called Trump quite early it was quite
obvious that I think trunk was going to
do surprisingly well and everything
since the political shocks 2016 has told
us that many on the liberal left are
completely and utterly lost they don't
have a meaningful reply to these moments
well this is exactly my concern because
what I see since 2016 is the very people
who should have taken that as an
opportunity to listen and to go well
first of all how did you do this right
do you know listen to Steve Bannon about
how he thinks he achieved what he
achieved getting Trump elected but also
listen to the concerns of the people who
did that like you know I was against
brakes and he was a massive wake-up call
for me when brakes and Trump happened
and it's led to this process of us doing
the show because I wanted to understand
people from different sides in their
opinions but it seems to me like the
Democrats in America the far left here
in the UK they're doing the opposite
that doubling down on exactly the things
that helped to lead to breaks and help
to get from polluted well I I mean I
completely agree except I wasn't
surprised by by break so I thought break
oh no no but I thought I thought breaks
it was odds-on I always thought the
fundamentals
favor break sir you know it's just that
everyone got lost and they wanted
groupthink triumph people saw what they
wanted to see basically and they
completely lost sight of what was going
on around them and when you have a
referendum like that against the
backdrop of the refugee crisis terrorist
attacks in in Paris the battle and the
suicide bombings in Brussels 20 years at
which the surveys had shown us
consistently more or less the more than
half of Britain's population either
wanted to leave the EU or wanted to
dramatically reduce the --use powers the
fundamentals were there what the vote
leave campaign did as an aside which was
ruthlessly effective was the slogan take
back control which was emotionally
resonant but also gave people a personal
sense of agency that they could take
back control now irrespective of whether
you believe it whether you don't and so
on just from a campaign point of view it
was it was ruthless now what I see in
the u.s. today is is the emergence of a
new strategy that I think might be as
effective at Donald Trump last week said
the Democrats have moved so far left
they're going to turn us in to Venezuela
and in a way it's Trump being Trump
right but on another level I think that
is a message that will resonate among a
mainstream American audience that is
looking at Elizabeth Warren falling over
herself to show that she's connected to
Native Indians or never the never-ending
search for identity politics quest for
recognition everybody's a victim when
nobody can be brought together I think
American American voters have have had
enough of that and I think the the
backlash to it may be stronger than we
currently anticipate we can see what
will happen at the midterms and in
Europe I think at least it's more
interesting to see people on the left
like the new rise up movement in Germany
which is trying to say okay in order to
win back AFD voters we can't argue that
this is all that economic scarcity
because clearly it isn't you know but
maybe we need to actually revisit what
we're saying about the social and
economic model so they've now started
saying well why don't we have a why
don't we have a pause on mass low-skill
migration and why don't we try and think
about how
we can boost productivity wages and
innovation without this never-ending
search for endless low-skilled workers
because maybe that isn't producing a
social settlement that is making
everybody feel happy that people do also
care about community nation
you know belonging and so on and I think
that's why in a way that parts on the
parts of the left in Europe might be
ahead of the curve the Democrats are
completely and utterly lost
I mean framing themselves as the
resistance talking about the democracy
being hijacked they're using they're
using militaristic language in order to
frame the response to Trump and that's a
very very dangerous game to play
you know Trump outplayed the Democrats
leave outplayed remain and I would argue
national populism is out playing social
democracy so there needs to be a much
more serious period of self-reflection
about what's gone wrong and my last
criticism is that these parties
movements groups think tanks on the left
only really invite thinkers and speakers
to their events who confirm what they
already think right if you look at all
the keynote talks the guest speakers you
name it it's people who already you know
they're preaching to the converted
they're not even putting themselves in a
difficult place they're not even putting
themselves in uncomfortable territory
whereas national populism I think has
actually gone on a far more and he's
troubling in a way but it's gone on a
far more rigorous intellectual journey
over the last thirty years than many
people on the Left have but if you go
back to the 80s and the 90s the new
right in France in Italy these thinkers
were basically trying to explore how the
National populace could take the ideas
of people like Gramsci and left-wing
thinkers and apply them from their own
ideological standpoint there's not much
innovation going on at the moment on the
left about all the interesting ideas
that are going on in the West in general
or on the
and I don't say that as somebody that
identifies openly if being on the right
I just say that somebody who is looking
at the intellectual debate all the
momentum is with people who are pushing
back against identity politics it's
pushing on people people who are pushing
it back against the liberal consensus in
a way and saying well what's next you
know cuz clearly this social settlement
this status quo is unsustainable
so maybe hopefully we'll get that
Renaissance on the liberal left that
will come into the marketplace of ideas
and bring something new because at the
moment there's not a lot that's new I'm
actually quite enthused by what you're
saying I mean take the Democrats aside
and they have gone absolutely apeshit
they've gone crazy you know I see mazie
Hirono telling men to sit down and shut
up and I think that's not a message it's
gonna resonate with the wider public it
just isn't but if you set that aside and
the Democrats in America going crazy and
you look at the rest of it isn't this
brilliant democracy at work where you
know something didn't work for 20 or 30
years and now we have a movement that's
through the democratic system without
large-scale violence or any of that is
getting the voice of the people back
into the mainstream of the conversation
and as you make the point in the book
even if these parties aren't necessarily
getting elected they're changing the
conversation that we're having and
they're bringing it to the right or
further to the right of the far left
that it's been on for so long well
that's certainly a view that that I
would that I would share but of course
the dominant view is that that would be
that's an apologists line on what's
happening in the West that actually what
we're seeing is the collapse of
democracy around us if you go to
waterstones
and you just look at the latest wave of
books that have come out post trump post
brexit it's you know how democracies die
you know the end of the world you know
it's all this alarmist stuff about you
know young people giving up on democracy
it's all nonsense I mean if you look at
the most reliable gold standard research
surveys that we have support for
democracy is incredibly strong and
entrenched 85 90 percent of people
saying I want to live in a democracy
I value representative democracy I don't
really want to go into an authoritarian
regime but we have a lot of
now particularly coming from the left
who really like to push this alarmism
this idea that the world is collapsing
around us I think partly because it's
because they don't really know what else
to say I think their world is collapsing
because their world is collapsing they
don't really know what to say they don't
really know how to respond to it and as
a consequence it's easier to kind of
preach to the Audion a preach to the
Guardian Easter's I guess and say well
actually you know the world is going to
hell in a handcart and it's quite sad to
watch to be honest because you if you
look at the British debate I mean the
one or two journalists who are pointing
out actually it's not all bad that we're
getting some some conversations going
that should be happening if you think
about I mean people like John Harris at
the Guardian you know everyone says all
it isn't he cool by going up to
Blackpool and pointing out that they
might have a point by voting for brexit
I mean there's there should be 20 of
those journalists in the british debate
you know but instead we've got this very
insular inward-looking discussion that
isn't really getting us anywhere near
understanding why people are feeling so
lost and forgotten you know one in two
colonists even today it went through
Oxbridge I mean it's not surprising they
didn't see the tide of working-class
Angus coming through 2016 yeah I mean
it's just and ever since then I mean
look what we've had since there and it's
just like well maybe an anti brexit
centrist party is the answer I mean who
can who seriously can look back in the
last two years and think the answer to
this the reply to this is more economic
and social liberalism like who I don't
understand how you could even reach that
conclusion right that you
there's no interesting intellectual
experimentation there's no new project a
third way in the 90s was kind of a neat
response partly by some on the left he
went way too far and it wasn't perhaps
as economically interventionist as it
should have been but it for that
particular time it was quite an
interesting response by someone on the
left now there is no similar response
there's sort of nothing it's just a kind
of vacuous space and then we wonder why
these alternative movements that are
meeting the left on the economics now
right so when the pen says I'm anxious
about savage globalization a lot of
people on the left in France
whoa - you know Amazon is taking the
piss IKEA are taking a bit maybe we
should prioritize domestic workers but
but they're also out flanking the left
on the cultural axis - because the
formula today is very much economic
security and cultural security and if
you can unlock both then the audience is
very big fantastic stuff yep well we're
coming to the end of our interview and
the question that we always like to ask
at the end is what is the one thing that
no one's talking about that we ought to
be talking about the future I think
where we're going and I think it's going
to be a lot more challenging than we
even realize at the moment that the
levels of volatility that we've seen if
you buy my argument and I don't mind if
you don't but if you buy my argument
that the bonds between voters and the
main parties have now broken down to
such an extent that we're only going to
see a lot more volatility going forward
and that the issue agenda in the West
with these big complex identity issues
on which the Left doesn't really have
much of a response it's going to also
favor the right and national populism
and we'll see more polarization as some
middle-class professionals break off -
the greens and the radical left I think
the pace of political change over the
coming years is going to surprise a lot
of people I think we need to start
talking a lot more about how to prepare
for that how to respond to that how to
ensure that we have the marketplace of
ideas and support it as well as we can
we have the institutions that do a good
job of doing that perhaps we need to
think about electoral reform but
actually need to think about getting rid
of the House of Lords and stuff like
that having citizens assemblies how can
we get ready for this period because
we're going to see a level of churn and
change in the West over the next 30 50
years that I don't even think we are
close to comprehending at the moment we
have someone on the show a couple of
weeks ago talking about the future I'm
not dismissing a point is a very good
point and do you think we're going to
see increasing fragmentation of
political parties do you think you know
the three of us have lived essentially
two party system for all our lives do
you think the way coming to the end of
that as a result of some of these things
or when you talk about fragmentation are
you talking about kind of more mental
fragmentation as opposed to out there no
no I'm talking about real fragmentation
I mean I think when I mean volatility I
mean you guys switching your votes from
one election to the next and won one
election you lip them then you're
conservative then your labor then you
cable in your whoever right and you're
constantly changing there's no tribal
allegiances a little bit like a Central
and Eastern Europe where you have really
quick changing PI systems and I think
what we're going to see is a lot more of
that a lot more party systems where the
two big main parties come down smaller
parties do better we're already seeing
it in Sweden Germany Netherlands
Portugal I think we'll see a lot more of
that polarization maybe over the long
term you get these the emergence of two
new blocks but they're more radically
distinct more ideologically incoherent
more irreconcilable more polarized and
that will that will create new problems
but even in the UK to 2015 and the 2017
elections were the most volatile that
we've had in the post-war period now
yeah we had 80 percent of the vote going
calm enorme but underneath that you had
Lib Dems going labour you keep going
conservative conservative going labour
some Lib Dems going green some green
going labour you name it we had a lot
more churn so there is certainly space
in the British system for a different
type of party it's not an anti brexit
centrist party it's one that is actually
accepting a brexit wants to have
slightly lower immigration but it's also
a bit more economically interventionist
but it's incredibly hard to break
through under the current dynamics that
we have and now without European
Parliament elections it's even harder
because you don't get that injection of
PR politics once every every five years
but we will across the West see a lot of
churn and change and it might be the
book at five star in Italy
you could start a party tomorrow that
trigonometry party and within ten years
you could you could win an election or
you could be Emmanuel macron and you
could say I'm stepping out of the party
system and you could become president
within 18 months
you could be Mateos Albanian in Italy
and you could be the only political
party now that's growing
what started as a pretty small northern
separatist movement is now eating its
way south through Italy eating up the
rights vote now beginning to attract
five-star voters so we're seeing changes
that are truly historic and we're living
in them which is exciting also quite
challenging
isn't that the Chinese curse I think and
may you live in interesting times I
think that's what we're doing a fridge
magnet well that's where all the wisdom
is nowadays anyway as you can see the
future's bright the futures trigonometry
in that vein subscribe to our channel as
always follow us at trigger pod follow
matt you're on twitter and very active
user on twitter by the way you like it
for a living
I like it I like it this is a
marketplace of ideas absolutely and you
are there at goodwin MJ Goodwin MJ and
tell us your book is called just
national populism the revolt against
liberal democracy which is out on
October 25th with penguin perfect which
is a couple of days after this interview
comes out but get the book I've read big
chunks of it it's very very interesting
and well-written
you'll enjoy it and there's always tune
in next week for another fantastic
episode thanks so much for coming up
thanks for having me wonderful stuff
don't forget to subscribe click the
little bell icon and that will tell you
when our videos are released and also as
well if you're listening to this on
audio you really like it if you can
leave us a review would be infinitely
grateful see you next week guys thank
you very much
[Music]